This episode of DNews is brought to you by
the all-new G Flex 2, from LG.
Life’s Good
You know what’s almost as annoying as losing
your keys?
Forgetting your passwords...
Hey guys, Amy on the Internet with DNews today,
and I’m not the only one online.
We live a lot of our lives online, which means
we end up having a lot of accounts requiring
passwords, anything from email and online
banking to that one time you had to create
an account just to buy an amazing pair of
shoes.
So it’s maybe unsurprising that we tend
to get a little lazy with our passwords, even
though every password-protected account holds
personal data we wouldn’t want made public.
Every year passwords are leaked, and SplashData
pulled together the 25 most common passwords
of 2014, out of 3.3 million that were leaked,
and it shows just how lazy we are.
A lot of people pick things they type quickly
and easily based on the arrangement of the
key board.
Numbers in sequential order are common, as
are letters in the order they appear on the
keyboard.
“qwerty” it turns out, it a pretty common
password.
Obvious combinations like “abc123” or
“111111” are also common, and so are words
like “superman,” “batman,” “football,”
and “dragon.”
But what if a password wasn't your only way
into your online accounts?
What if the way you type your password was
part of the password?
A team of scientists led by Jun Chen of the
Georgia Institute of Technology say they’ve
developed a self-cleaning, self-powered smart
keyboard that can identify computer users
by the way they type, which could help prevent
unauthorized users from accessing your accounts.
Their research was published in the journal
ACS Nano and funded by the U.S. Department
of Energy.
The team’s smart keyboard was designed to
sense typing patterns, including typing speed
and strength of keystroke.
These physical characteristics vary from person
to person, meaning the smart keyboard can
distinguish between users.
Someone could know your password, but if they
try to type it on a smart keyboard it wouldn’t
work.
Sensing the specific keystrokes of its owner,
it would lock the attempted intruder out,
alerting you to the attempted breach while
also recording and identifying the intruder.
And this keyboard even has some bonus smart
features.
It can harness the energy generated from typing,
converting the mechanical stimuli applied
to the keyboard into electronic signals that
can power either the keyboard itself or another
small device.
Another bonus: its surface coating actually
repels first and grime!
But it’s possible that passwords, even those
typed on a smart keyboard, will soon become
a thing of the past.
At CES this year in Las Vegas, Biometric IT
devices were touted as the hottest new thing
in online security.
Some cell phones already unlock with fingerprint
recognition instead of a password, a technology
some companies are incorporating into biometric
digital wallets from companies like HyprKey.
So while this smart keyboard is still just
a prototype with no clear timeline for commercial
availability, it’s still a pretty amazing
entry in the growing field of biometric security.
So what do you guys think about smart keyboards?
Cool or creepy?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.